because the taxes are tell you
everything about a society and the
arguments as as Steve has so eloquent
eloquently documented in his book they
the arguments about taxes tell us a lot
about our political social and economic
history as well so it he happened to
have chosen the subject that I'm really
passionate about and I love the book and
I'm sure you're gonna love it too Steve
Weisman editorial thank you very much
Carla and thank you all for coming and
thank you my friends for coming and it's
I want to just tell you what an honor it
is to be here because this this place is
a wonderful institution and I've been
here many times in the audience
including for my wife whose book was
presented here some years ago whose
books were and so it's a particularly
wonderful fruition for me to be here
I'm not we didn't really discuss format
so why don't I just tell you a little
bit about how I came to write this book
and what I was trying to do in it and
describe it a little bit and then I'll
be happy to take questions and talk
about it in more detail one of the
hardest experiences of writing this book
I think over the last few years was to
see the expression on people's faces
when night when they said what are you
writing a book about and I said well I'm
writing a book about the history of the
income-tax
and people would say well good luck
Steve that's that certainly sounds
interesting
nobody said oh I love the income tax for
some strange reason so it was a pretty
odd challenge that I set for myself well
why did I do it well I think one of the
reasons is what Karla just said that
although taxes are a distasteful subject
for all of us and something that maybe
we don't like to think about most of the
time in fact we are passionate about the
subject we argue about it incessantly
and not only that our arguments are of
the highest at the highest level of
morality what is fair to the individual
in our society what's fair to our
society itself and I think through the
kind of taxes that have evolved in our
country we see we get a window into what
kind of society we are and want to be
and I don't need to mention of course
since at least 1980 which was the first
presidential election that I covered as
a reporter for the New York Times
taxes have been at the center of all of
our national campaigns and we've been
engaging in that argument for a long
time and and most passionately obviously
with the arrival of Ronald Reagan who
was sort of the poet laureate of of a
certain school of thought and ushered in
a period where we've mostly been talking
about tax cuts although in some years
about tax increases well I I wanted some
of you who know me and others who can
see my background as a political
reporter for most of the time that I've
been a reporter going back to the 1970s
when I was covering the financial
emergency in New York
when New York City almost went into
bankruptcy some of you remember that
I've really been interested in this
subject but and I wanted to write a book
about it I wanted to write a book about
fairness about justice and about the
great principles at stake in our society
and I have to give credit to my
wonderful editor Alice Mayhew who many
of you know or have heard of who one day
I said to her I really want to write
about this subject in the current era
this was in the mid and late 1990s I
think there's a resurgence of a kind of
progressive impulse about in American
society that really kind of interests me
and Alice said you know I'd be much more
interested in you're looking at the
Progressive Era when these attitudes
first got started and that touched off
an interesting sort of spark with me
because around that time it was in the
limit or late 1990s there were these big
arguments about the flat tax you
remember Steve Forbes and I
simultaneously had curia out of
curiosity just started looking at the
origins of the income tax I didn't know
very much about it but I wanted to
frankly see if there would be some good
quotes to use from some of the people
who originated the tax maybe that could
freshen up some of what I was writing my
editorials and then I saw I delved into
it and I found that associated with the
income tax were characters like William
Jennings Bryan we think of him as the
great commoner the author of the cross
of gold the 1896 presidential candidate
who seized control of the Democratic
Party and transformed it for the next
for really for the next century
I found Oh a character like Cordell Hull
who many of us know as the Secretary of
State during Franklin Roosevelt
period he was the man who the Japanese
visited on December 7th to announce
cutting off relations and they didn't
realize that Pearl Harbor that he knew
that Pearl Harbor had just been bombed
great character in history turns out he
was one of the primary authors of the
income-tax when he was a congressman
from Tennessee back in the early 20th
century back in 1913 1914 the tireless
champion of it and he'd grown up in a
log cabin in Tennessee and rose to a
position of a lot of prominence so I
began looking at the 1890s I love the
1890s I love the turmoil the upheaval
the more I saw the 89 he's focused on
the panic of 93 which was the greatest
economic crisis the biggest depression
and economic downturn in American
history until the Great Depression of
the 1930s the panic of 93 was a
remarkable story there were marches on
Washington there were protests they were
unemployed boarding the trains roaming
the country looking for food looking for
jobs there was a in the land and out of
this turmoil out of this sense of
protests of the wealthy not paying their
fair share for the government and most
of the revenues for the government being
paid for by tariffs which were
effectively a sales tax of as much as
50% on all the goods that people had to
buy for their livelihood their clothes
their shoes their machinery if they were
farmers this was a just an exciting
period for me it resonated so much with
current history so I plunged in with
that thinking that I would write about
the 1890s and then maybe go up to 1913
when the tax was finally ratified but as
a constitutional amendment this was a
great period of turmoil the tax was
enacted by Congress
it was then overturned by the Supreme
Court as unconstitutional the Supreme
Court then was plunged into a political
fight it was attacked in the country
even Brian himself attacked it people
accused him of having designs on the
court of wanting to pack the court it
was exactly like you know what like the
year 2000 the court was seen as brazenly
political and ideological and
overthrowing the tax then after I
studied the period of the 1890s I did
that thing that I think is alarming to
all editors of all authors when I let my
editor know that I think I didn't want
to start at the 1890s I wanted to go
back to the 1860s I thought that's where
the story really has to begin because
the tax was enacted in the Civil War and
you know editors suddenly get the shakes
and think you know that eventually he's
going to say this has to go back to the
Roman Empire everything or the the Bible
or something which of course there were
taxes and taxes on income forever since
since the times since biblical times but
I instead I went back to the Civil War
and that was one of the greatest
adventures for me I'm by no means a
Civil War buff there maybe even be
people in this room who know lots about
the Civil War and we're all fascinated
and devoted to who the telling and the
retelling of the Civil War but what I I
got this idea that who paid for the
Civil War and it turns out that the
literature on that is not that extensive
but it was there was a huge fight in the
Civil War Lincoln versus the banks the
banks didn't want to lend the money
without some promise of being repaid
they were Patriots their patriotism
wasn't always appreciated at the
my house or at the Treasury Department
but they wanted to be repaid and that
debate that fight about borrowing should
we borrow for the war should the Union
raise taxes for the war and if it raised
his taxes who are they raised on it was
incredible to me how reminiscent of the
debates that were having today was the
fight during the Civil War in fact there
was one moment when I was doing the
research on that period where I actually
was interviewing somebody who was then
working for governor george w bush and
he said to me I think that what Clinton
did in the early 90s was immoral to
raise taxes on the rich just because
they're rich is immoral and literally
like a day or two later I was going
through reading the debates in Congress
and Thaddeus Stevens who is better known
as an abolitionist you know one of the
doctrinaire abolitionists but he was
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee and his family was owned an
ironworks in Pennsylvania said it is
immoral to raise taxes on the rich just
because they're rich I mean it was
almost word-for-word
what I was hearing today I mean it just
couldn't believe that these debates were
so similar bless you and then finally
after getting through the Civil War
I did not alarm my editor even more and
go back to the Boston Tea Party he or
other tax or you know the whiskey
rebellion I mean our nation was founded
and in many ways on the concept of a tax
revolt I went they left a head went from
the 1890s up through the Progressive Era
Theodore Roosevelt was the pivotal
figure he's everybody's favorite
president certainly every president's
favorite president he's a great
character he's been written about so
much and yet I found there was something
to to explore there was something I
didn't
and about Theodore Roosevelt and his
what was it that gave him this great
antipathy toward great wealth the
malefactors of great wealth I mean he
was a man of considerable wealth he
inherited a pretty good-sized fortune
but it turns out he struggled for much
of his life because although he was a
man of some wealth his tastes were in
excess of those of that wealth and he
was always writing to his wife or rather
his wife was right when he was in the
badlands his wife was writing to him do
you think we could get some money to
turn up the heat at Sagamore Hill and so
I just well I I found it was interesting
to explore his attitudes towards wealth
he proposed the income tax it was
carried off across the finish line er to
that maybe the ten yard line by his
successor William Howard Taft who I was
fascinated by and I'll spare you a
little bit of that we can talk about
that later if you want it I wanted to he
put it over the top and with a
constitutional amendment in 1909 which
he and everybody else in the Congress
thought would never pass why it takes
three-quarters of the state legislatures
to approve a constitutional amendment
and there were that meant at the time
only a dozen states that it could have
blocked it they were what you won't be
surprised the wealthiest states
including New York but the election of
1910 by the time Rosa Teddy Roosevelt
and Taft split open the Republican Party
the Democrats the progressives the
reformers swept into power in 1910 and
to the surprise of everyone they put the
tacks over the top and ratified it
literally finally only weeks before the
inauguration of Woodrow Wilson and it
was then that I realized that I had to
go still one more step in the narrative
and tell the story of World War one I
like the idea of having a book that
begins with the greatest war
that America has ever experienced and
ending it with the Great War World War
one which to my amazement forced another
debate over fairness and wealth and
raised the top rate of the income tax to
77 percent before the war was over we
usually think of that rate is associated
with World War two but of course that
was a very expensive war in terms of
lives lost and the cost of it so that's
the arc of the book that I ended up I
decided to stop there and I felt this 60
years told the period of the great
struggle that laid the foundation for
the tax since World War 1 of course the
tax has fluctuated it went down in the
1920s back up in the 30s and 40s for
World War two and then down again
starting with John F Kennedy who was as
many of you know a tax cutter and then
all the way through Reagan era to the
present day and I feel just too close
that I'd like to think that this is a
timely book because we are headed into
two crises right now we're headed into a
possible war that's going to be very
expensive the White House says a hundred
to two hundred billion dollars the last
Gulf War was paid mostly by our allies
in fact I was living in Japan at the
time of the first Gulf War and the
Japanese had a suspicion that the Allies
you know that the United States might
have even made some money off the war we
don't I don't know
if anyone's looked at the books but
certainly the United States did not have
to pay for that war as its going to have
to pay for this one and I believe that
if history is any guide I believe our
debates are rooted in history and if
history is any guide we're going to head
into a sharper debate about wealth and
fairness and will that will force us to
reconsider the Bush tax cuts it'll be a
healthy debate it's the kind of bait we
should have especially at wartime and I
hope that in the by looking at history
in the way I have maybe I can illuminate
some of that anyway so I hope I haven't
gone on too long I'd be very happy to
talk to you and have a conversation
thank you again for listening and I'll
be happy to take any questions you have
friends on c-span can hear us when we
use the mic if you just had that short
question that that will be fine go ahead
I wonder was the IRS the the
organization when it wasn't back in the
Lincoln's time when they wants to had a
headquarters that sent out the tax forms
and yeah when was that a staff that was
in Lincoln's time it was the Internal
Revenue Bureau instead of service at the
time it had an office at the Treasury
Department and the first IRS
commissioner was a man named George
Boutwell who later went on to become
Treasury secretary and I actually ran in
the other ran into the other day a
Sheldon Cohen who was a former IRS
commissioner we discovered we were the
only people we probably knew who had
both read George Bout Wells memoirs
he set up shop they he was a man with a
certain sense of humor they put up a
sign quoting the Gospel of st. Luke you
know that the word went forth from
Caesar that all that everyone should be
taxed and that was there by word they
made up the rules each evening with a
group of individuals and then sometimes
Boutwell would get on his horse for
exercise in the afternoon or the evening
he describes how he went over to the War
Department where Lincoln would sit
hunched over in a shawl looking at the
latest bulletins from the war and he'd
ask him how the war was going the
immediacy of reading that is it was just
amazing yes
how did differences of perceptions of
what government should do affect the
people who were forming tax policy
during this era 1860 to 1920 that's a
very good question someone asked me
recently what was the biggest unintended
consequence of the income tax and I was
I thought about it and I think it is
that this was a tax that was launched
and established to fund war and it ended
up of course funding the welfare state
that we know the great social democracy
that we have but in the period 1860 to
1920 there were social programs to pay
for there was no Social Security system
but after the Civil War the pension
program for Civil War veterans and their
widows and orphans as Lincoln said care
for their widows and their orphans was
huge it was a big expense so there was a
big debate about that in fact a
succession of presidents got into fights
with Congress over pensions it was like
our Social Security system it was a
universal veteran
benefit and pension program so that was
one thing that and war and also the
other thing that the tax paid for was
public works projects which were the big
program of the Republicans not the
Democrats the Republicans were the big
spenders and Lincoln believed in it
believed in building canals railroads
roads to connect the country the
Republican Party was founded on the
principle of opening up the less
populated areas with government
intervention and government expenditure
there were other parts of the country
that did not favor that and you see if
you in the debates about the tax in this
period there's something very similar to
the arguments that we're having now if
we raise this tax it'll just go for pork
barrel projects in other parts in the
country spending money getting votes and
that was also an argument that that the
tax generated
yes hey what can you compare the
relative success or failure of the North
and the South in raising revenue for the
civil war yeah the the question was to
compare the success of the North versus
the South and raising revenue for the
war well one of the discoveries that I
made and I did say this to one of my
colleagues who is a Civil War buff is
that if the South had been as fortunate
in its fin and Sears as it had been in
its generals it might have been able to
last longer in the Civil War there were
two problems one was that the South was
a decentralized entity after all that
was the cause for which the South fought
to oppose the despotism of Washington so
there was a problem in organizing the
South to raise taxes that was what they
were fighting against secondly the South
opposed tariffs because they were
punished by tariffs the remember the
South exported something like eighty
percent of the cotton that it produced
70 or 80 percent overseas it came back
in the form of finished goods clothing
and sometimes 50 percent higher than
they would have otherwise paid so they
were founded on opposition to the tariff
so that ruled out the tariff as a way to
raise money what did the south - I think
it's famous they printed money and their
money soon became so worthless that they
were trading in stamps or you know for
the counterfeit money their money was
absolutely worthless the North also
printed money finally the North was not
the great success story they printed
greenbacks midway through the
or there was a concern that they that
the greenback's would be held as
unconstitutional but the North struggled
through in part because of the income
tax and although there the ratio in the
North was unhealthy in an unhealthy way
more toward borrowing than taxes and
provided an example that for the rest of
the century and into the 20th then
everyone did not want to repeat their
they were more successful in raising
revenues from tariffs and taxes and
ended up very quickly in the late 1860's
and into the 1870s in the Union was in
good shape and running up surpluses yes
I have a question and it's because I
don't understand how it works I guess
but this bit of income tax okay there's
a certain percentage go to the state
when it's collected from the state and
the rest go into a common pot for the
whole United States and who decides what
part of the common pot in the United
States goes for other countries and one
more part of this question I don't mind
helping people but I'm pretty tired of
having it taken from my pocket always
not being able to do anything about it
why can't we send people overseas to
teach the people in the other countries
how to raise their own money and take
care of themselves now that I really
sound very adamant and well anyway
that's okay you get the message it's a
subject that we have strong views about
first of all just to answer the first
question back in the war of 1812 and in
the first part of the history of the
country when there was a crisis the
federal government did in fact raise
taxes simply by saying to the states you
give us you raise the tax any way you
want and send it to Washington but that
was a very inefficient system it led to
unfairness different states raising them
in in different ways actually the the
South tried to do that during the Civil
War they would assign an amount of
revenue to the states they knew they
shouldn't borrow well guess what the
states then just went and borrowed it
and sent it to Richmond in that case so
the federal income tax that was enacted
was a tax all of which was collected for
the federal government now
tax paying overseas I guess that would
be another book you know my wife and I
have lived in Asia and we lived in India
for four three and a half years that's a
country of a very poor country but
there's a lot of wealth in India
especially now but even going back to
the days of the Maharajah's and boy
Indians just they don't they don't pay
taxes it's like what you read about the
Russians who may I think maybe some of
you saw the story about how the Russians
adopted the income tax it was a flat I
think it was a flat rate
it wasn't progressive but and it wasn't
a very high rate but it was a real step
forward because although it wasn't a
high rate the idea was to get people
used to paying taxes but in places like
Russia or India or a lot of countries
that are poor but have wealth what
people do is they shelter their wealth
overseas in bank accounts abroad that
even happens in Israel and other
countries I guess it happens in the
United States too and it's it's very
hard for us to you know inculcate that
taxpaying spirit into other countries I
guess we have enough trouble persuading
our own people to pay taxes
at Japan while you were talking cuz I
was gonna ask you about that
well Japanese tax rates are very high I
don't think there is the level of
evasion in Japan there that there is
yeah I think the Japanese are are very
good about paying their taxes and maybe
somebody in here can correct me on that
but the Japanese society is a much more
intrusive society into your private
affairs and private bank accounts and
they keep track of it and the tax taxes
are very high there the Japanese however
are also running probably one of the
highest budget deficits in the history
of government right now and but that's
for economic reasons not because I mean
they're trying to stimulate the economy
and not because people are evading taxes
yes sir yes I was hoping you could talk
about the techniques and opportunities
that Americans had during the time that
you studied for tax evasion and tax
avoidance and presumably there was no
Switzerland or Cayman Islands to to run
- yeah well that's a very interesting
question you know after the tax was
enacted Mark Twain
filed something like $36 tax and he
wrote a letter to the IRS saying that he
was really proud he finally felt that he
was proud to be recognized by the
federal government and it made him feel
important I don't think that was a
typical ad but the extensive evasion
evasion was a did has probably grew to
be a problem much later in the history
of the tax especially when loopholes
started to open opening up in the more
recent decades but you know
one of my favorite moments in this
period is the debate in 1894 over the
enactment of the income tax and evasion
was a key part of that debate because
opponents of the tax argued we can't
raise this tax because it'll just be
evaded people will cheat or people and
if they don't cheat it will require an
intrusive government to come in and look
at their books that was appalling to
Americans in the 19th century and there
was a prediction by some that people
would go overseas and evade it and going
that the wealthiest Americans would just
evade the tax by moving overseas and
Brian you got to read his speech it's
just great you know he gets up there and
he says he turns to all the congressmen
they said oh I see you're worried about
cheats you know well you must be talking
about your own constituents if you know
them so well I mean it was a master
rhetorician and then he said and he had
done his research he was a prodigious
self-taught person who did not like to
go to social events in Washington he
loved to spend his time in the library
the Library of Congress studying history
and he ordered the State Department to
do research on taxes in all the
countries of Europe and he said well I
guess you're afraid that tax payers will
go to Europe well that's very
interesting he said now let's see where
would they go you know and then he
started listing all these countries well
will they go to England well maybe
they'll find that the income tax there
is already higher than this one that
you're proposing and maybe they'll move
to Prussia and maybe they'll move to
Scandinavia and he went through all the
countries that everybody said they would
move to and he just demolish
the argument and then he ended with the
with quoting from the man without the
country country about those who would
you know move abroad just to evade a two
percent taxes their patriotism really
only two percent deep is that the kind
of country he want we want so I'm not
sure the answered your question about
the extent of evasion if there's always
been tax evasion it's always been a
problem that people have wrestled with
in ways very similar to the way we're
talking about it now with corporations
moving to the Cayman Islands or whatever
and but the real problem of tax evasion
comes a bit later yes young man the book
covers six decades what was the most
challenging thing the most challenging
part of writing the book and what was
the most fun well not surprisingly
that's a hard question I think the most
challenging thing of writing narrative
history in a book like this is when to
step back and give background and
explain when you're introducing a new
character you suddenly have to go back
in time and when you're writing you have
to constantly be aware of keeping the
narrative going and not interrupting
every time you introduce a new character
and yet that was very hard for me
because my curiosity you know went would
fan out every time I found somebody
interesting like Thomas Sherman who was
a big corporate litigator in New York oh
he's an interesting character why did he
know so much about wealth and then I
began studying the history of the law
firm of Sherman and Sterling and then
actually they helped me and they said oh
well you went to Yale which is where I
as an undergraduate sterling Sherman's
law partner endowed the Yale Law School
and all the sterling professors there
and I thought oh gee this is not
interesting you know
well you just you have to get yourself
you have to control yourself when you
when you're doing a book like that so I
think that's the hardest part of the
writing it and the most fun part it's a
nice question I think is just you know
I'm a political reporter by trade I've
covered politics all of my career for
the New York Times I've had a great
[Music]
experience and it's been a great
adventure for me I think the fun of it
was looking at history and writing about
it
as if I were a political reporter and
trying to provide the context but
capture the personalities and capturing
the issues and the intertwining of them
capture that debate I was talking about
before with Brian and his opponent who
was one of the Democratic bosses in the
house and you know excuse me just
following the you know the the 1909-1910
election campaign which is not a
campaign that many people care about or
know about just the little moments like
when William Howard Taft was campaigning
and he was presented with a bathtub and
he he enjoyed getting the president
until he found out that the people in
the Midwestern town that gave him the
bathtub wanted him to take a bath in
front of them he weighed 300 pounds they
they thought that month must be
something fun to see so it really I
think the most fun was seeing how alive
politics were and trying to recapture
that and write about it as if you know
just as the political reporter I am 3/4
of the states required to approve the
constitutional amendment
can you illustrate further some of the
states that did not approve of the
amendment yes let me talk for a second
about the one state that initially did
not approve it and then change then that
was New York because New York was pretty
typical during the Civil War I can't
remember the figures exactly but
something New York paid something like
25 or 30 percent of the entire federal
income tax with only a small much
smaller percentage of the population so
not only the Republicans but the
Democrats everybody in New York was
against the tax and once New York voted
against it everyone thought that the tax
was dead and they affected a lot of the
other states including the wealthy
states which then were New Jersey
Connecticut Rhode Island New England to
some degree Massachusetts remember these
were that what these were the states in
the 19th century that wealth were
Factory that were that were the heart of
American industry
it was the agriculture states and the
far western and the and the ranching
states and the rural states that were in
favor of the income tax because it was a
tax on the wealthy States and so when
New York switched in the great election
of 1910
I keep coming back to that don't I and
elected it was a tremendously
interesting election to me the more
there was a more interesting election in
New Jersey in 1910 a new governor there
named Woodrow Wilson same situation that
flipped New Jersey over to the yes
column and and in New York as well the
holdout states one of the one of them
for instance was Rhode Island and I
think in Pennsylvania was a holdout they
were remember back then the
Legislature's
were both gerrymandered and they still
had this was before the Supreme Court
decision in the 1960s of one-person
one-vote
so legislators tended to be dominated by
their own rural interests and they in
turn were dominated by political bosses
and political bosses were in turn in
many cases in bed with the wealthy
interests in the state from whom they
got money
so Rhode Island was a clot of rotten
boroughs there and you know those are
legislative districts that hardly have
anybody living in them but we're still
represented they were they continued to
vote against ratification yes have you
found that the the antipathy against
versus the understanding for paying
taxes has remained pretty constant over
time or has it changed over time I have
to be in particular periods that people
were more understanding versus less
understand yeah well you know Woodrow
Wilson said that paying taxes was a
glorious privilege I don't think that
that was typical of most Americans at
any time but obviously war time makes
Americans more willing to pay taxes and
it also makes Americans more willing to
lend money to the government the big
bond sales of the Civil War Jake hook
you know we're successful and in World
War one the Liberty Bonds but on the tax
side people are willing to accept as a
matter of sacrifice paying taxes so I
think that's the short answer
but the other thing is that Wars tend to
accelerate or accentuate the basic
arguments that we have in our society
over fairness and wealth you know we
have been through a period of the 1990s
obviously where Americans celebrated
well
and saw the great and I believe this is
a constant impulse in American society
to see to admire people who are wealthy
because wealth represents I believe to
most Americans to some degree a reward
for good behavior
as Ronald Reagan would say saving
investing working hard taking risks you
hear George Bush talk about that we
shouldn't punish people who do these
good things by taxing them
disproportionately and that's an impulse
that always has existed in America going
back to the Civil War contrary to this
is the sense that we need to keep
society together we need to have a sense
of fairness you know at the Civil War
during the Civil War if on the Union
side for most of the war you could pay
$300 and get out of the draft and there
was a moment in the Civil War where the
Treasury Secretary salmon chase his
daughter was getting married in
Washington it was a big Society of it
everybody attended except for mrs.
Lincoln who resented the this young and
beautiful daughter and salmon tastes
bought his daughter a $3,000 shawl at a
department store in New York Stewart's
department store which along with Brooks
Brothers was one of the big department
stores at the time and you know that was
the cost of ten lives people in wartime
especially are acutely aware to these
inequities they that that was the kind
of consideration that led to not only an
income tax but a progressive income tax
that was higher on those who were
wealthy
Thanks I have a was had recently
listened to founding brothers by Joseph
Ellis and was overwhelming
overwhelmingly struck by the how the the
fights the the the disagreements that
have persisted throughout our history
and Ellis does a very good job of in a
very economical way showing you how
these the founding brothers face some of
the same issues that we would be facing
years hence and I think Steve does
exactly the same thing in this book by
focusing on the decades from the Civil
War to the first through the first world
war he is able to illustrate the the
debates that took place then that we
would be having in the 40s and in the
80s and 90s and and that we're facing
all over again right at this time and
it's a real tribute to to Steve's book
that it received a wonderful review by
somebody who I dare say is a lot more
conservative then Steve is yesterday in
the New York Times a great of
a review by Bob Samuelson which pointed
out what a fair-minded and and and fun
to read book it is which it is so um
thank you very much Steve iners
congratulations to you and the books are
for sale in the front of the store
you're watching book TV 48 hours of
nonfiction books coming up at midnight
Eastern a look at the influence of
Wahhabi Islam and its ties to the Saudi
royal family with Stephen Schwartz
author of the two faces of Islam then
meditations of Marcus Aurelius with
translator Gregory Hays Sunday night
Robert remedy profiles Mormon Church
founder Joseph Smith after that on
public lives a panel featuring
biographers Robert Kira